[Music]
a symbol of celebration throughout her
reign now bringing solemnity
gun salutes echoing across the country
from edinburgh to london
marking the end of an extraordinary life
flags everywhere were lowered
bells tolled up and down the country
mourning the death of the queen
the usual business of parliament has
stopped and ahead of speeches mps
reflected in silence
her late majesty queen elizabeth ii was
one of the greatest leaders the world
has ever known
she was the rock on which modern britain
was built
the united kingdom is the great country
it is today because of her
the commonwealth is the family of
nations it is today because of her
the prime minister's first audience with
the king happening in the same week his
mother appointed her
on mourning her death we have looked
back remembering a glamorous young queen
who would become for so many the
nation's grandmother
and so something very special has gone
people joining a collective sense of
loss
hundreds queueing in the hope of getting
a seat at a special ceremony at some
pools
just a most inspirational
positive
wonderful woman
with a sense of humor
a sense of loyalty
to her people and her family
i'm one of the best mothers any country
can ever have i will certainly never
know another female monarch and she
probably won't either
um and that was a strange thing to think
about especially being a little girl you
know she was such a
you know a strong constant for all of
these years
and you know and that's gone and that's
that's sad whether you support the
monarchy or not
in a place of sanctuary where only
months ago her family and friends had
remembered her remarkable service and
celebrated her platinum jubilee the
congregation were encouraged to look to
her example
as we mourn her loss
give thanks for her life
and reorientate ourselves as individuals
and a nation to life without her majesty
may her words remind us
of the power and strength to be found in
coming together
[Music]
much about the coming days has been
scripted and planned but it is the
public response to this moment that will
mark its place in history
rhiannon mills sky news at buckingham
palace